[Music]
hi
everyone oops sorry my name is allison
hill i'm a data scientist and
professional educator
at our studio welcome to learning and
using with r our first speaker is gina
reynolds
[Applause]
hey good afternoon yes my name is
gina reynolds and i'm here to talk to
you today
about flip books and a new package for
creating them
called flipbook r just a little bit
about me
i teach at the university of denver in
the corvell school of international
studies
and i co-organize denver our ladies
i tweeted ava mayray i also write code
and github i'm ava ray there too
and i used to do um quite a fair amount
of blogging
um on netlify but i've been
recently writing a lot more flip books
so just as a traditional
flipbook allows you to watch the
evolution of a scene
our new code flipbooks allow you to
watch the evolution
of a code pipeline
so formally flipbooks present code and
output
side by side and step by step
and they deliver to you something that's
like a stop action movie
uh based on like looking over the
shoulder of
somebody that's actually building up a
code a coding pipeline
and taking snapshots at appropriate
moments
um like they're checking their code uh
checking their work along the way and
intermediate output
so i think to understand where we are
with the project right now
it might be useful to look back in time
to look at the origins of this project
and i'd say that in 2018
we were in the era of the proto-flipbook
so
garrick aiden bowie and i and emmy
tanaka were all
interacting with this idea presenting
code and output
side by side and building it up
incrementally
but at this time the project
that the projects that we were building
were very handcrafted and artisanal
so we were all crafting each slide
that composed each mini flip book
one by one using a lot of copying and
pasting
but i was excited to find these
like-minded people
and and so i approached them
they seemed to know a lot about the tool
that we were building with
sharingan and i asked them do you want
to build
flip books together
we were all circling around this idea we
thought that flipbooks could really
deliver
a great experience to users deliver of
them
a lot of insights about what's going on
in a code pipeline
but to really reach flipbook's full
potential we realized that we had to
move away
from this copy-paste modality we had to
move to
something that unburdened the creator of
flipbooks
so we moved to automation so
now we're automatically parsing a block
of input code
and automatically reconstructing code
into partial builds
and then automatically delivering these
partial builds onto a presentation
platform
2019 has uh was a year of exploration
and refinement
we were interested in how we could use
this new tool
different modalities to use it um using
other people's code
breaking the flip book building code
that we had developed
and in 2020 you can build a flipbook in
five minutes
with flipbook r which is a development
package
on github using um sharingan as well
so we are going to do just that we're
going to build a flipbook in five
minutes
um but first a little bit of background
we're going to use ggplot2
in the demo but we're going to use a
dialect of ggplot2
called slow gg plot and slow gg plot 2s
literally only the wonderful
gigi platchu
so everything that we're going to be
doing is native
2gg plot 2 and fully supported
it embraces incrementalism and feedback
so for every decision that you make
you're going to want
when possible to have one ggplot
statement
so you may be familiar with
more this way of going about creating a
gg plot where you have a statement
where your your data is defined and your
aesthetic mapping
and then you say what a geometric object
you want to take on those aesthetics
and then say what labels you want
contrasting this with slow ggplot we
start with
data pipe that into ggplot statement
um move to declare our
x position aesthetic our ry position
aesthetic
our geometric object and then we can
move to
non-required aesthetics and the label
statements
will make each of these decisions get
their own ggplot statement
so the behavior that we're going after
then will look like this
we've got our code on the one side
and output on the other
okay so let's begin our live
demo
so delivered to you with the package
is a template so we can open that up by
going
to our markdown and then from template
you'll grab a minimal flipbook
and we're going to keep the yama and
basically this will walk you through
a lot of modalities that i'm going to
talk you through earlier so i'm going to
just delete
most of the contents
and just keep the last code chunk which
is css this is going to allow you to
adjust the code
font size pretty easily okay and then
i'm going to include
a code chunk we're going to use the tidy
verse
and of course flip book
r
then i'm going to add
a slide break 3 minus signs
no space and we're going to start
building our
code pipeline so i'm going to just use
the car's data set
pipe that to ggplot
and we can check our code as we go
add the aesthetic mapping
i'll have x represent speed
and y represent
distanced
and then add my geometric
object
and let's just do some multiple mapping
for fun
we'll have color also represent
speed
okay so this is our source code chunk
and we don't actually want it to appear
in the flipbook
so we're going to set the code chunk
option include
to false and
then we're going to refer to this code
chunk
with a name i'm going to call it cars
and then we'll use
uh the flipbook function chunk
reveal
to reveal this coding pipeline
so the first argument here is the chunk
name
that's cars and we're all set to build
our
flipbook so i'm going to
hit knit here in our studio save this as
the flip book
and you can see that the build is
happening
and you've created your first flipbook
so um what's going on
is i'm using actually the auto
mode of display so what's being looked
for is
balanced parentheses and these are good
places to take
breaks along this coding pipeline but
you can also use the
argument break type
and set that to user
and with a special comment break
in capital letters
you define where you want breaks along
this pipeline so let's just have a quick
look at that
so two break points okay
so um i'm gonna present to you a few
more modalities that you can use
um an additional one is
setting a break type to non-sequential
so this could be used in a context where
you want kind of this behavior
uh for something to appear in within
your pipeline
but not right away so here i would use
that
non-sequential setting and then set the
break
to here break
and then the number two and then break
three here
we can also set the break type to a
integer and you might think of this as
like entering the multiverse
where you want code to be revealed
multiple times just the same code and
this would be appropriate in a setting
where you're doing some
sampling so taking a random sample so
here i'm sampling with replacement
sample fraction replace equals true
we have these multiple realizations of
the same code
you can also set the argument display
type
so the default is to display both the
code and the output side by side but you
might
want to display just the output
so maybe in a more traditional setting
in a presentation setting where you just
want to slowly
present each component of a plot
you can also set display type
to code just display the code
maybe with students thinking about uh
what what their expectations are
as you build up a plot you can also tell
longer stories with flip booking
so you might use a source
code chunk and do some wrangling steps
and then create an object within that
code chunk
and then have another source code chunk
where you're doing some plotting
so that would look something like this i
created cars mod
and then working from there i
pipe into a plot
so you noticed that i used right
assignment here
and you might be asking yourself well
can i use left assignment
and flipbooking allows for this too
and you just set the parameter left
assigned to true
and what we do then is track the first
object
that you create in your code chunk and
print it
at the bottom of the flipbook
and you can use flip booking beyond the
tidy verse as well
for example with this modality where you
kind of chain by overriding an object
so here you would set left assignment to
true again
and you can also use brackets and
logical indexing
by using this dot bracket syntax with
the magritter pipe
that would look something like this and
you can use with booking with base our
plotting
too okay
so we've shown you that you can build a
flip book pretty easily
but it does take a little bit more
effort so you may be asking yourself
is it worth it
and i would argue that it delivers a lot
of insights
to newcomers when they see a long
pipeline of code
i think that maybe the message is
something like this
and even for more seasoned
practitioners i would say that on an
unfamiliar
code within a long pipeline it may be
possible for them to
infer what must be going on with that
code but i do think that
this might require a lot of mental
gymnastics
which flip booking alleviates
so um
what does flipping do for us though
right so we're showing all these
intermediary steps
but we could show them by infinitely
scrolling through the steps
the question i'm asking is what does
temporal offset
afford rather than spatial offset
so this is the example of
spatial offset we could scroll through
the different states
but spatial offset requires us to gauge
engage
in visual search which requires
focused attention and concentration
you've probably experienced this
but with flipbooks you're delivered this
blink comparator type experience
where you observe different states
superimposed
and aligned
and this is a blank comparator um
it was uh used to super align images of
the night sky
um in at different points in time and
it's credited
for the discovery of pluto
we found pluto several decades
earlier than we would have other
otherwise
motion detection makes discovering
differences easier
to conclude i would say that flipbooks
has
a lot of potential in educational
settings
but also for reference you might
if you're using a pipeline frequently
but um
but not frequently enough to recall all
of the steps you might make a flip book
out of it
and come back to it in the future and
also for communicating
what you're doing with colleagues and
peers
i also think that flipbooks might be
useful in
creating greater transparency because
what api
we're using shouldn't make
people feel like outsiders it should be
clear
what's going on no matter what pipeline
we're using
so i want to issue a good a big thanks
to garrick adam bui
and emmy tanaka for helping get this
project off the ground
and i'm also really grateful to a lot of
critical infrastructures
that make the pop the project possible
to testers for their code review and
to volunt volunteers um
many of them from tidy tuesday um the
initiative
uh to see what would what would break
flip booking
and support at the university of denver
that's it
okay well here i'll just push this way
so we have a few questions and we have a
little bit of time
there's the timer uh so our first
question is
can you use chunk underscore reveal
within a markdown document like a block
down page
a markdown report etc so the flip book
works like a gif
instead of a slideshow
so at this point
no so the output that you get is
like a full website so
it's the output that sharing gives you
which is the full website
um we are looking at different
modalities different
presentation platforms that we could use
so
one of one of the things that we're
working on is just delivering
a gif so using actually
yeah combining images
so that's that might be coming up
yeah and then uh one more question uh do
you
when do you expect flipbooker will be on
crayon
um may i guess
no promises thank you hey talk
thank you gina
you